messieurs dames bonjour comment allez
vous je suis présentement avec lucio moi
comme ça parce que longtemps tenu sur
ces deux ans c'est l'académie quand
crime sans naïveté l'écouté huawei j'ai
rien et piquer un bébé j'avais pas
dribbler
il est permis je suis pompier volontaire
mais pourquoi vous a laissé tony l'a
écouté je vais tout vous raconter nous
sommes dans essayé de rester calme 2 la
suite vous souvenez avec seb le serpent
la mygale la femme araignée le but
c'était quoi de monter le moins possible
en bpm donc de rester le plus calme
possible aujourd'hui lorraine a mis les
bouchées doubles la regarder ce sourire
malicieux l'être quand un adulte a l'air
je suis ravi bon on nous a filé s'est
tenu jusqu'à me tenir à garder un tee
shirt et yoko il va être dégueulasse en
six jours mais ne savez pas vous
connaissez les épreuves peut-être nous
avons sur nous comme la dernière fois un
capteur cardiaque franchement même
moyennant au bpm à l'image en direct
aujourd'hui ce sera quatre épreuves on a
un peu gris très léger je voulais seront
jugés par rapport à la dernière édition
je vous donne aucun indice vous allez
découvrir on va commencer avec la
première épreuve je vous dit rien moi je
serai à mon poste d'observation je
servirai lequel d'entre vous montre le
puissant bpm par contre parenthèse je ne
sais plus qui avait gagné la dernière
n'ont plus qu'à tu as la note de 12 sur
20 et septua la note de 12,8 j'ai perdu
j'ai le sommes je crois je crois que
c'était moi j'ai rien et il semble que
c'est toi aussi ok on
[Rires]
est bon on va aller à l'épreuve numéro
une je vois souvent des lécheurs alors
j'ai apprécié parce qu'ils soient ils
sont ils plus ou pas
vous aurez pas plus confort que c'était
hier pour l'instant atteint la frange
sais que je vais la laisser comme ça
c'est très bien je vois pas je suis
assez stylé vous êtes prêts oui c'est
parti allez allez raisons êtes-vous
après m'abandonnait les gérer maintenant
je voudrais n'avoir donné sur le bord de
la route
alors magna d'abord ce matin moi d'abord
nommé le style a porté
chance ou cela ou c'est mon tour dirait
bien que moi aussi j'ai ballasté hockey
à droite auger touche étoile à seulement
20 ans je te lâche plus allez arrêter un
peu les peurs qu'est-ce que vous êtes
lent stop chamakh là tu viens ici voilà
c'est une partie du matin ici tu marches
pas
déclarée terrifiée je suis pas là elle
est tombée elle a continué à avancer
tout dit tu descends pas citer
cpp qui te sont tellement vous êtes trop
d'où
ma classe bien mais tes mains sur les
épaules de maga file indienne ok ok
listerine derrière toi t'es mort je sais
que dans un film d'horreur je mourrai
avant toi ma g pas tant d'efforts
passant les portes il ya plus de bruit
du tout c'est le petit train de la
rigolade
van uden la gueule ok on y est les
petits copains
déjà sachez que vous avez un bpm
supérieur à 100 tous les deux
actuellement et ça doit me gay je pense
parce qu on est tellement que
j'en doute pas et je pense que ça va
continuer de veiller à mon avis
l'objectif de cette épreuve et tente de
sortir de cette boîte comment allez vous
sortir de cette boîte c'est simple c'est
moi qui vais vous ouvrir je ne vous
ouvre la porte que si vous arrivez à
descendre votre bpm en dessous de 80
vous avez le droit des zap raison de
retirer votre masque et l'épreuve pourra
commencer avec un compte à rebours de
deux minutes faut rester calme c'est sûr
c'est un truc de regarde y'a des parois
elle dans celle ci
si tu respires tout doucement sur la
bête est resté calme toi c'est très
désagréable parce que tu es à la mère
pense à la plage on a combien alors m
130 ha ouais voilà c'est quoi acheter
une technique
tüv adopter l'enfant sortie avatar je
suis honteux les éléments pas de panique
magda je suis versé l'eau c'est mon truc
mais de l'eau dans la nuque ça va
refroidir notre température
ok envoyer les requins
âgé qu mouillé moi je vais me lever
quand même vous arrivant bientôt à la
fin du compte à rebours qui n'avait
toujours pas descendu à petit couronne
non mais vas-y ils vont libérer des
trucs là dedans encore quelques secondes
des petit crapaud mais c'est sûr d'être
avant de lâcher les sangsues
il ya un petit bpm qui est remonté à 2
en plus mon futile et mal mais sur mes
pompes l'âge comme moi pas beaucoup
je suis pas du tout en train de quitter
là encore quelques secondes afin de
gagner l'épreuve en fait comme on attend
un truc le fmi peut pas descendre sous
un certain niveau et c'est là où ils
sont trop malins mais en fait y'a pas
d'entrée c'est impossible s'il ya une
entrée regarde bouge ton pied d'ailleurs
ça c'est une antenne
encore un ça ne compte pas s'arrêter
elle prend du plaisir à ça j'imagine l'a
appuyé sur son bouton et faire un combat
avec eye et l'augmenter je parle pas
comme ça déjà
à lui car je vais arriver à 75 bpm temps
bravo à toi vaincu pour avoir su garder
son calme et son sang froid merci mais
pouvoir vous faire sortir de la boîte
c'est fini la
guinée tout va bien ça va bien ça va
c'est la première épreuve elle est
sortie à temps à la barre où je deviens
parano de malades là ma vie c'est devenu
le truman show est moi franchement je
vais dire il fait chaud aujourd'hui
l'âge et les chances dans l'eau je suis
vachement bien on va vous prendre demain
gary tâche et vous verrez qu'il n'y ait
pas de souci je vous sers pas à
l'inversé beaucoup on vous attend merci
beaucoup à vous sortez de ce truc
immédiate bon qu'avez vous pensé de
cette première épreuve moi j'ai eu peur
à un moment je crois je suis monté j'ai
eu peur qu'ils aient des trucs arrive
dans l'eau qui a gagné cette épreuve si
je pense c'est du quartier je sais pas
moi je suis arrivé dans un truc où il ya
de l'eau je déteste l'eau et thoune
surtout quand je vois pas ça me saoule
de malades il ya moi je me sois fait
avoir comme ça j le café
alors au maximum on est assez près il ya
132 et 139 et la personne qui atteint
les 139 semag la
première victoire pour alors magna on a
peur de l'eau en fait c'était une bonne
idée parce que on a spéculé à 800 moi je
suis bien pour la 2eme direct c'est très
bien je suis en confiance je suis serein
et oui vous avez peut-être vous changer
après moi je vous ai fait tomber
maintenant allez vous changer et après
vous êtes cette maladie va faire froid
mais dans un frigo
il perdrait genre un truc de boucher
avec des steaks hachés congelés
faut qu'on arrête de spéculer
c'est une demolition party ou quoi non
on va détruire des trucs à il faut pas
toucher on ne touche à rien pour
l'instant est ce que vous connaissez les
petits jeux stressant quand vous êtes en
plus jeune docteur maboule et c'est bon
on est pareil on est sur une épreuve de
concentration dans tous les cas il va
falloir vous concentrer tous vos chakras
pour faire passer l'anneau ici je pense
que c'est avec ce petit truc non je
pense quand je touche il prend un coup
de jus et du coup comme tu as peur
d'avoir un coup de grâce à mes côtés je
vous laisse sur ses terres mais
attendent a dit le ou pas si ça envoie
de l'électricité bah ça vous allez vous
détruire
qui n'ont commis en fait je pense que tu
as pris un café donc ce serait bien d'y
aller en premier alors oui j'ai pris un
café là entre les entre les deux
épreuves donc notamment actuellement
j'ai genre 5 bpm de plus il est
également allé pisser donc il a - bt
monk stan eu oui c'est ça que ça marche
comme ça c'est si magna une fois la met
un pansement genre salaires potes elle
connaît trop tout ce qui est genre c'est
le centre cardiaque je vais aller à mon
poste de contrôle vous observez et qui
commence à manquer perdu l'épreuve déjà
d'accord
à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
alors attendez pourquoi il ya un gant ça
veut dire tu risques de te brûler parce
que ce truc là à la cram et qui est
l'ingénieur les gars vous avez pas pris
des élèves de 3e en cours de techno et
vous leur avez dit petit truc de torture
pour ce quiz et verglas et si déjà
l'épreuve après on parle mais tu peux
pas prendre de coups de juste alléguant
celles ci vont brûler mais moi aussi
magna est déjà sans oui même temps c'est
normal celle qui commence
basée à toi je prie pour qu'il y ait un
sursaut de malades ça se trouve ya rien
quand tu touches ouais
ta mère
voilà c'est ça qu'on voulait
au des petits des
pnj
[Rires]
magna mais c'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'on fait l'épreuve
terrible
j'ai pas sur son bien ou plus ou
moins de pression je préfère battre mont
lucas se greffe un effort fait le
correctement
[Musique]
dans l'autre sens
je passe un super bon c'est pourquoi ça
m'a fait que ça j'ai un gros blême avec
les gros bruit par exemple les toilettes
d'un avion
chaque fois je fais ils redescendent un
peu trop la première est de cibler toi
elle s'était un peu clown et en face à
l'aller pour toi et celle là lé clan
pour moi j'aimerais vraiment d'une
relance et les cafards sur la tête c'est
bien joué et maître du jeu la prochaine
édition boîte gay soit plusieurs cordes
à mon arc il a tellement peu de cordes à
son arc j'ai tellement fait ce petit jeu
au carmel à l'école primaire très
touchée 0 fois je vais prendre tout mon
temps il à faire n'importe quoi
il remonte y remonte
donc que je vais être impossible en fait
j'en peux plus j'ai un acouphène d'un
mariage ap
oui
[Applaudissements]
qui a conçu cette cette merde dès qu'ils
n'y arrivent pas l'objet d'insultés a
été entier attendait faut qu'on
m'explique pourquoi j'ai un gants de
vaisselle est ce que c'est juste pour
que l'équipe technique se foutent de
notre gueule louer ces gens j'en peux
plus
il est juste excessivement
[Rires]
[Musique]
lesquels
vraiment pas qu'il fasse froid
brouillard
c'est la pire épreuve c'est de la torre
c'était mon jour j'arrive
c'est abominable c'est plus tard aussi
chaotique ces genres trop dur tu as vu
la taille de la noë puis le chemin ça
mais ça regarde ailleurs c'est
aujourd'hui je pense que ça représente
un petit peu la société de consommation
et ça représente mes tympans après cette
épreuve ça représente une deuxième
manche de gagner pour lui
alors vous avez tous les deux dépassé
100 sauf qu'il y en a un qui s'arrêta
sens et l'autre qui monte jusqu'à 128 au
delà c'est une grosse marge mais je me
suis excité c'est sûr que ce montage
parce que je suis dead genre moi le
premier truc tu n'as pas vu parce que je
cachais ma faiblesse il m'a tellement
fait peur le bruit me suis retrouvé là
comme cette vitre il ya la traduit mon
visage est la vitre et si j'ai pas loose
tu vas m'entendre célébrer ça tellement
pendant je suis désolé mais il va faire
du bruit parce que tu as perdu
[Applaudissements]
vas-y
mais célébrer sa sobre mais tout n'est
pas perdu ok il reste encore deux
épreuves intense c'est tout ça qui
arrive regarde
moi la courage à toi ma soeur je sais
que c'est dur oui mais c'est toi qui a
commencé l'onmt avait plus de pression
ouais c'est ça ok la prochaine je
commence à bouger c'est vrai que c'est
une tachycardie s'écoule elles refluent
tachycardie tous les médecins qui
regarde la vidéo ils sont là j'en
attendais 120 bpm pour cela c'est parce
que quand tu fais beaucoup de cardio ça
mon but en fait tu fais pas cette fois
donc tu as réussi à me rabaisser alors
que j'ai géré le truc mains tape à gérer
ton coeur sin merde tu vas aller voir
son but est maintenant de
la rigole mais je vais te dire ce qui va
se passer on va passer un bon moment les
go va bien s'amuser à les paul est mort
des treize d'être bonne humeur l'avoir
moi je suis très bonne humeur je mène
2-0 je trouve hersinois ça va pas durer
c'est à dire
assez salée preuve le faire à peu près
sur l'usd-yen conclure il a su monter là
nous arrivons à la troisième épreuve
dont clarens dernière vous allez avoir
un couloir il y à quatre portes que vous
pouvez ouvrir les autres il ya un
pansement dessus là donc on y va un
pansement way sur la porte elle est
blessée à chaque fois vous les ouvrez
ensemble vous rentrez dans la pièce vous
posez vous attendez 10 secondes et vous
ressortez par contre excuse moi mais là
c'est quand même quatre épreuves en une
nuit c'est l'épreuve des portes
[Rires]
les mots de twitch moi j'avais sur mon
poste de contrôle et je voulais cette
petite promenade retourne dans sa tour
d'ivoire et maîtrise de valeur
on y voit s go ok ça c'est le couloir
est un peu sombre à temps à démarrer
regarde les lumières à ses rôles ou
d'hommes sérodifférents
hockey
ont pu tester le lancement de portes
allers fait une annonce assez neutre
attendez les gars les bandes avec
marquez danger de mort électrocuté
non mais c'est pas une porte qui fait
partie du jeu
[Musique]
elle commence déjà à monter ce thème
auquel primero une première porte on est
sur quelque chose de ces chiffres c'est
un peu une petite blague pour commencer
une petite mise en bouche est ce que je
vous demande dans le cosec de ce mois la
première un coup sec la deuxième
dames saute à la gueule
[Rires]
quand il fait jour il n'est pas
impressionné de rien ils montent quand
même à 100 kw
jours la deuxième tu veut l'ouvrir aller
en faites pas je pense que la première
c'est de la merde et les autres c'est
horrible magna magna est stressé vas-y
[Musique]
vas-y rentrer
chien j'adore
le cas est bien monté là pas trouvés
mais cela ne leur donne ça fait dix
secondes
les mondes
ces patates et ça c'est votre héros
c'est ça c'est une erreur
c'est bon
j'espère que ça monte merci cela à
bientôt thunder j'ai pris le pas sur
l'arbre a plus on va regarder fait
ma glace en 6 ok
les gars entamèrent une carole monte
à bata je crois que j'ai sauté en bpm
pas à moi l'escrimeur audio ça me fait
dix fois plus peur que mes trucs
physiquement si les trucs en face de moi
qui me away attends je suis resté avec
sound of
là c'est le bureau de la reine mary
balogh on arrive lolo
[Musique]
c'est moi qui louche du coup
c'est pas le montant plafond
pour combien cette approche 2 euros
vas-y
c'est pour ça que les 10 secondes on a
fait dix mois c'est pour la
suite la grand mère c'est ma grand-mère
déjà sera pas
[Musique]
vasile touffu la tête après je pense
qu'il va j'ai fait monter ton bébé n 1
bonjour madame au revoir madame sa vie
sur dix ça c'est horrible tout ce que je
déteste mais attend la dernière porte
c'est le bureau de lorraine ou quoi je
prends que sur rendez vous s'il vous
plaît
vous êtes passé par d'octo libre oui
exactement oui c'est pour çà tachycardie
alors je pense m'être fait avoir sur le
truc tout con je rentre dans la pièce et
il ya un petit cri la lame a mis ses os
rim et moi c'est vraiment les sondes
c'est qu'ils me dégringole au cerveau la
mamie c'est terrifiant je l'entendais
chantonnay de la base c'était mauvais
pour rythmer les sacs allait courir
ramallah en fait j'aurais pu la frapper
c'est à dire que ça ne le fait elle
ferait tomber leur merde j'ai tué
d'intermittent
mais vous avez été très proches sur les
vmc quelle pièce on a le plus bas la
famille est le cri et le crient il ya
quelqu'un qui est monté plus que l'autre
mais
alors c'est très serré parce qu'on a dû
120 et du 123 mais le pic à 123 été
atteint avec l'escrimeur audio chez moi
parler car
tu vas leur gagné une manche à tintin en
toi dans le meilleur des cas il ya
égalité ouais mais une égalité c'est
très beau tu vois ça voudrait dire c'est
votre tour eiffel belle remontée mais
oui reste une épreuve donc si vous êtes
chaud trop chaud je me trouve dans la
suite au débat concurrentes
[Applaudissements]
par rapport à bush
l'a trop content
son corps à cette journée au spa ou quoi
aujourd'hui n'ont fait si l'un à temps
mais la parole eux ces dames il me fait
trop peur mais attend il ya un
traquenard ou quoi là c'est ce que j'ai
des trucs à vous donner haha mag l'enjeu
pour toi est énorme si tu gagnes à
égalité alors je me suis renseigné sur
ce qui fait le plus stresser les gens
j'en suis venu à la conclusion que vous
avez repasser le permis conduire je n'ai
jamais passé
justement il ya un moniteur qui vous
attend là qu'une voiture et les épreuves
jamais passé le cap sous la dans
la voiture et ses pierres de moins qu il
est les gens y vont juger les gens ils
sont habitués j'écrase tout dans les
jeux et ses tarifs habituels conçu comme
une bourrique donc je m'en fiche toi par
contre à la pression se fait à temps
mais arrête ici gouvernement voit la
vidéo et que je suis une trop nuls ils
vous retirer mon père lindsay qui veut
dire que tu conduis pas très bien c'est
moi qui conduis trop bien va t on à
faire votre trip toi et moi je conduis
trop bien faire il a quitté ou chantant
pas grand chose
[Musique]
tu es un peu trop sereine je trouve que
je suis trop content je pense que tu vas
entendre la voiture démarrer et on en
reparle jeu et les examens je te déteste
- ouais je déteste charge sur votre
dossier je présente son examinateur jour
chanter chanter qui va te faire donc
passer l'examen vous me détestez puis le
quart chanté et enchanté comme
s'appellent stephan stéphane warnet
je me souviens très bien de tout ce
qu'il faut faire comment dans une
voiture aurélie
a jeté trop bien cette classe là je mets
ma petite ceinture d'abord il faut faire
les réglages monnaie
[Musique]
alors mes rétroviseurs comment déjà par
deux chercheurs ont commencé vers 6 h
pas bon je savais au chili ashley je
suis un peu moins direct par rapport à
la grille horaire cherche pas vous mais
j'ai vraiment je peux passer le code
encore si je suis au max rétroviseur je
sais comment il se règle
pas réglé les rétroviseurs je veux voir
la fesse de la voiture il ya une
commande électrique
je suis un grand pilote mois de formule
1 j'ai beaucoup sur ces 300 trémousse
oui c'est important ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est vrai
130 c'est bien sûr la console mais dans
la réalité un talent des pilotes sur la
route en a beaucoup des accédants ça de
vue les chiffres de la sécurité routière
dernière ah ça y est c'est un peu
quelques mètres la sanch à ok c'est que
rennes va vous rigolez je pense qu'on va
perdre tous les plots pendant cette
manoeuvre et c'est une voiture manuel
exactement y'a pas de problème par
rapport à la à la voiture manuel la
voiture elle a démarré sa pipe je suis
prêt
dès que vous prétendez 20
direction la gauche donc là je mets mon
clignotant quand même ce que je tourne à
gauche quand même important de films sur
vingt deux parties en cela mais si
quelqu'un car et vous m incline à temps
leur honneur d'être donc voir y allait
du coup à pierrefonds l' accent sur la
plage soit ok trop cool vous savez ça me
rappelle des souvenirs abominable
profond et traumatisant sont un peu très
à gauche mais on est à peu près
intentions 102-103 on n'arrête plus oui
là bas madame micheline bien sûr 104 et
je dois aller ou poursuivre les plots
peut pas les toucher et à droite mais
gérard grave voilà je pourrais pas
passer le pit est là je pourrai pas vous
montrer un peu mesquine vous n'hésitez
pas à les imiter premières deuxièmes à
vous les voulez qu'on le fasse vite ça
nous plaise je t'en supplie renversé un
plot qu'on rigole il faut tourner un
temps passé dans le noir je vais
partir d'où regardez vous je vous ai dit
je vous ai pas menti je pense que je
vais vous en prie s'il n'est qu'ici on
en trouve a bien voulu que 66 le moment
tout va bien mais je suis désolé
monsieur parce que là si un piéton
carnet ces deux soirées thématiques et
le français droit ou milieu
j'ai calé à un petit calage j'imprime
avec les freinages souvent je connais un
peu tard une fois que l'accident ait
connu ouais il faut que la personne est
morte vous êtes inquiète en tout cas
j'apprécie tous vos bons conseils et on
accélère tranquillement ce
elle a l'air ravi de ce qui se passe là
fait qu un pic à 100 donc ça va elle est
hyper détendu et on va serrer tous tout
à droite tout à droite à droite avec
déjà
11 ans à un tour et pas un poteau rhin
ont offert un dernier tour on reviendra
au trust aidé à nettoyer chez nous c'est
ça ouais super j'aime énormément les
créneaux je trouve ça très bien monsieur
pendant l'examen faut rester concentré
je suis de nouveau parler c'est vrai
c'est le sait les marchés très nerveux
actuellement aucun n'a que des voitures
qui se garent toute seule en temps
normal ça chez le fai va devoir se
débrouiller là je m'arrache arriver on y
va comme ça en train entre les quatre
plots attendez quoi j'ai pas compris le
créneau s'est sentie bpm
alors ce que vous pouvez me montrer où
se situent les fêtes des pressions que
ces quelques par fars a actionné la
commande qu'on va
là non ça c'est le cas du gard et à
paris après vous avez vu on cependant ce
qui se passe là 30 km/heure des
trottinettes à tout va kiss kiss et des
pistes cyclables en voiture voilà je
sais même pas pourquoi je passe le
permis aujourd'hui pour mieux se
déplacer pour emmener mon chien en forêt
vous avez un animal non des enfants j'ai
tenté de nous trouver un point commun
allez faut se garer il ya des gens qui
attendaient un ebe meurette j'ai
l'impression d'être à l'école
c'est vrai c'est ma fille c'est mon
enfant alors j'ai découvert une
technique java brew tutoriel sur youtube
et je vais vous apprendre ce créneau il
est incroyable c'est lui qui fait sur
écrase un plomb je t'en supplie donc
foule droite et là normalement il ya une
voiture garée à côté de moi je repère
visuellement ou et sa plaque arrière et
lorsque la plaque se trouve au milieu de
ma vitre ici qu'est-ce qui se passe ful
gauche bas mot plat je vire de bord up
et là impossible là je fais un constat
que je perds abbaoui cachet touché une
voiture qui se passionne c'est vrai
ressortir de recommencer pas de souci
utilisé en première elle fait une
dernière petite manoeuvre vraiment
puisque serait pas la manoeuvre de trop
je vais un peu plus chiant brèche ok
[Musique]
alors comment oh la vache mais c'est
possible de faire ça mais on est dans
tokyo drift ou quoi on aurait dit les
voitures de pimp l'agent snoop dogg là
ça fait deux essais la route est bouché
les gens klaxonnent
dépêche toi connard ouais c'est bon je
me garaud toujours stressé c'est
parisien ici et là qu'est ce qui se
passe j'ai moins de choses ces partis
reviennent bien ça va très très vite
attention comme suit à la fin 2020 là on
arrête le bluff on arrête la comédie
pour la commedia dell'arte foule droite
let's go up là maintenant un peu tout
droit au plat full gauche il ya cadre un
des miens flou non mais là c'est une
catastrophe cet opus sur l'embrayage
qu'on mette la preuve elle n'est pas
mise la première là
allez on a remporté 7 / vouloir rester
en voiture avec moi on va prendre votre
père
jamais les chiens et les autres en
ignorance ça j'apprécie c'est très sympa
bah c'est franchement vous avez super
bien appliqué ce que je vous ai montré
quoi comme repères mes mots techniques
qu'on est d'accord qu'on pourrait
rentrer dans l'impasse car on pouvait
rentrer évidemment je peux partager avec
vous une sensation c'est très humiliant
épilogue dix fois mieux oh mais aussi au
siège passager là je viens littéralement
de vivre un traumatisme
la vie est un grand trop mince c'est
vrai
bon madame c'est pas le permis alors
venir on va monsieur ce sera pas pour
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment navré non à
vous le donner donc je vous apprends une
technique de créneaux de fou qui n'est
pas très bien faudra perfectionner à
noter les papiers j'ai pas le son mais
je connais suffisamment vigilante à
négocier a dit monsieur leur courage
trail l'appareil l'a pas il est déçu on
peut pas mettre des dangers sur la route
fac ou en entreprise ont fait de cette
super bien vous ce métier je vais
acheter un vélo électrique pourrait
intervenir demain il est mort trois
points de pau
mes cervicales aux nano thermite
ont permis d'annoncer je l'aimais en
plus mais créneau ça va dans la vraie
vie en tout cas le prof était très
sympathique il est trop gentil et est
devenu tournée vachement bien tirés
sains pour une fois vraiment excuse moi
moi est le permis s'est passé dans des
portes de plots ou être sur la route
fallait aller tôt car devant ce qui nous
intéresse la haute le fait que vous
n'ayez pas eu l'examen c'est de savoir à
combien on est monté et on a eu un
record lié le vrai examen non on a eu 1
130 et un 120 je pense que c'est moi
parce que je suis censé genre grappes
gérer vu que moi j'avais ça te met la
pression sa théorie ouais la théorie est
vrai
mon nom dans la voiture dans la voiture
mais je déteste les examens je vous jure
c'est genre ma phobie d'ailleurs respect
à tous ceux qui passent des examens tout
le temps c'est à dire tous les jeunes
sauf moi parce que j'ai trop de chance
c'était vrai nom du coup il ya égalité
mieux gagner à égalité
c'était excellent j'ai passé un même
bien être où les énigmes et a choisi les
épreuves et énigmes s'est trompé débrief
un débriefing vidéo disait on a trop
bien rangée c'était super les amis c'est
la fin c'est la fin je m'étais presque
habitué j'ai presque envie qu'il y en
ait d'autres merci à vous d'avoir
regardé merci mike ladd et venus me suis
trop plusieurs comme ça avec toi toi qui
es fan d'horreur et tout ça mais c'était
trop en lorraine et c'est vraiment tuer
à la tâche pour que ce soit vraiment des
épreuves beaucoup plus ouf que le
premier nous on a pris un plaisir de
malades j'espère que vous aussi en
regardant la vidéo n'hésitez pas à
passer par la chaîne twitch et les
réseaux de mag l'appareil pour lucioles
et puis au plaisir ciao laisse mise aux
normes à l'esc oui ça va être conduit
bien dans la vraie vie